the Battle of the presidents is back and
it's getting downright nasty former
President Obama using a virtual
commencement speech to take this cheap
shot at President Trump over his
leadership during the pandemic this
pandemic is fully finally torn back the
curtain on the idea that so many of the
folks in charge know what they're doing
a lot of them aren't even pretending to
be in charge if the world is gonna get
better it's gonna be up to you but Trump
was ready to fire back I think he was an
incompetent president I think President
Obama was one of the worst presidents in
the history of our country I think he
was an incompetent president
all right so digging mcdowell do you
think Barack Obama's obsessed with
President Trump just a little just a
little
maybe President Obama was being so
passive-aggressive
he didn't even he didn't even name
President Trump that's like picking a
fight with somebody in the Wawa parking
lot by shoving him from behind and then
run and buy and going and hiding behind
the dumpster out back that being that
being said President Obama was speaking
to historically black colleges and
universities our graduates this year and
that's a real trouble spot for the
Democrats it was back in 2016 where
there were 4.4 million
Obama voters who state from 2012 who
stayed at home in 2016 and more than one
third of them were black voters and
Michelle Obama in her that documentary
becoming herself said it was painful to
sit on that stage the day I left the
White House and that a lot of our folks
didn't vote it was almost a slap in the
face so that's what he's trying to do
he's trying to make sure those people go
out and vote for Biden in November I
actually got into a fight at a Wawa
parking lot when I was in high school I
bet you it didn't go well for me and I'm
just gonna leave it like that
mr. got fell what do you think about
these two presidents going after each
other in the middle of a pandemic well
it's it's never a surprise with a with
Trump the media always frames
conservative talking points as red meat
for the base what Obama delivered is
blue meat for the media
yeah the media loves this self-righteous
superiority makes them feel comfortable
in their arrogance we're so much better
and we're so much smarter but I'm not
gonna give you any plan or ideas or
suggestions to help how about that
pandemic playbook that was hilarious
so here's the thing in this next phase
you need to eliminate distractions and
that means thinking critically about the
future and stop criticizing to pass
we're gonna make mistakes in this
process and as long as we correct them
quickly we can all be on the same team
left right center you name it but the
moment you return to the past of
pointing your finger without offering
any solutions you are cut from the team
so Obama just got kicked off the team
he's no longer on the team he's just a
big whiny crybaby oh wow Barack Obama
just got cut long I'm off the team I'm
usually the one that gets cut yeah do
you even make the team Greg anyway Juan
do you think Barack Obama is just bitter
because Trump shredded his legacy is now
exposed um as corrupt with the Spygate
drama Wow Wow
I don't think that's the case but I'll
let you stay right there in your own
fantasy land I I didn't even think what
Greg said was right about that I mean
what happened this weekend was was it
this weekend or Friday Mitch McConnell
the Senate Majority Leader had bought
into this idea oh you know Obama didn't
leave any kind of plan there for a
pandemic and then he had to walk it back
and say oh that was not right I was
wrong
did you see that but I mean it's a lot
like did you see the plan it so
everybody seen the plan in fact in fact
in fact Greg what you hear from the fact
checkers is this is a pants on fire
checker misleading claim coming from the
Trump administration and where is the
Trump plan that's but the bigger issue
watching right now stay tuned our
localities are all working that for New
York City and New Jersey federal plan
liberals no leadership
no leadership coming from the top
ignoring the CDC Jessie said all those
people that are see max Jessie I'll sir
here's to you had we don't know how
Obama would have dealt with this but I
will his personality more low-key I
think he would have been more trusted ah
personality okay okay don't ever cite
fact checkers on the show on I mean
their fact-checking is atrocious Dana
what do you just think about kind of the
historical significance and me do these
things happen when next presidents go
after you know they're their
predecessors like this does this happen
well I guess it depends you know Jimmy
Carter was never really quiet forty-one
very much was 43 tried to follow his
father's lead President Obama went after
43 all the time the one time that
President Bush was hoping the back was
when remember when the Obama
administration was thinking about
prosecuting a interrogators and that
wasn't about 43 personally that was more
about doing the right thing and
protecting the been asked to do really
hard things so no but President Obama it
you know he's been fairly quiet I would
say that after being called a criminal
all weekend his little shot there in the
middle of the commencement address was
maybe a little mild but we're all
missing the point every time that there
is we're not talking about Joe Biden
means that somebody else is filling that
vacuum and I know that President Obama
would love to try to fight this for
Biden because he's not landing any blows
himself but Joe Biden has to win this on
his and I'm Paula thinks if he had been
the candidate instead of Hillary Clinton
he would have beat President Trump but
keep your eye on the ball this is about
the candidate is going to be Joe Biden
it is not going to be Obama but I think
President Obama is showing that he is
probably going to campaign in a very
different way than former presidents
have in the recent past maybe it won't
even be Joe Biden you never know how
things turn out all right